en Italie l'arche victoire de la
coalition nationaleiste aux élections
législatives avec 43% des voix selon les
résultats partielles Georgia mélodie
devrait diriger le prochain gouvernement
nous serons appelés à gouverner cette
nation et nous le ferons pour tous pour
tous les Italiens
nous le ferons avec l'objectif d'unir
notre peuple au moment où toute l'Europe
se réveille après la Pologne à Hongrie
la Suède et l'Italie cette nuit et bien
je vous invite à devenir adhérent du
rassemblement national remplacer
monsieur Draghi par Madame Meloni ça
pose quand même un certain nombre de
questions moi je veux pas faire de
procès d'attention à quiconque mais
draguer était quelqu'un de
d'extraordinairement sérieux et efficace
pour aider l'Italie effectivement le
peuple italien a voté hier moi je veux
pas commenter le choix démocratique du
peuple italien une femme qui a défendu
malgré parfois les difficultés à faire
cohabiter tous ces mouvements l'idée
d'une coalition à droite donc de se
rassemblement des droites pour gagner et
je crois qu'en France on devrait avancer
aussi vers cette hypothèse qui a une
très grande inquiétude de chez les
peuples et à laquelle il faut répondre
une inquiétude qui tient aux questions
d'identité on verra si les choses
deviennent compliquées j'ai parlé de la
Hongrie et de la Pologne nous avons des
outils
je crois une leçon donnée à Ursula
vanderleyen qui a tenté de faire
pression de dire si vous ne votez pas
correctement vous les Italiens on va
vous sanctionner vous savez à chaque
fois ça donne un résultat inverse
exactement ce qu'elle a dit oui enfin
c'est quand même une espèce de petit
chantage démocratique
mais la question est de savoir comment
les gens défendent la démocratie
nous verrons le résultat des élections
en Italie nous avons également eu des
élections en Suède mon approche est que
quel que soit le gouvernement
démocratique qui est prêt à travailler
avec nous nous travaillons ensemble nous
mettrons également en œuvre une réforme
des retraites
pourront le faire de manière juste un
rythme raisonnable
vous allez allonger le durée la durée
les engagements du Président de la
République je dis même que on a prévu de
revaloriser les plus petites pensions
donc du coup la solution c'est en effet
de décaler progressivement l'âge
effectif de départ à la retraite le
faire en rapide rapidement l'ouzed d'une
certaine manière dans un amendement pfss
c'est inacceptable pour la CFDT on a
besoin d'un vrai sujet un vrai débat qui
intègre quoi qui intègre la question
d'équilibre des retraites c'est pas un
sujet tabou pour la CFDT on fait des
poses des pronostics sur les mouvements
sociaux je dis toujours que c'est très
compliqué mais alors là il y en a un que
je fais sur les retraites il y aura un
mouvement social d'ampleur secrétaire
national d'Europe Écologie Les Verts
Julien Bayou annonçait ce matin sa
démission il est accusé de harcèlement
moral par de violence morale par son
ex-compagne et d'après lui c'est
impossible de se faire entendre et
impossible de se défendre
s'il y a des plaintes bien évidemment on
traitera ses plaintes en l'occurrence
c'est des débats internes à Europe
Écologie Les Verts je vais pas m'en
m'aider peut-être juillet elle envoyait
à Julien Bayou un courriel menaçant et
ne
inquiète toi je vais revenir et en force
dans ce courriel elle assure de sa
volonté de le mettre je cite hors d'état
de nuit et elle lui prédit je cite
toujours une chute douloureuse le
procédé qui consiste à aller sur un
plateau de télévision pour mettre en
accusation quelqu'un de son propre parti
alors que on a aucun élément de preuve
il y a quelque chose de
d'inquiétant dans tout ça Julien Bayou
constate avec amertume et colère
l'instrumentalisation du juste combat
contre les violences sexuelles et
sexistes à des fins politiques
personne n'ignore que le Congrès les
écologistes se tient en fin d'année
l'ambition politicienne ne saurait
justifier toutes les croisades
Julien Bayou après avoir fait rentrer
dans ce piège d'Emmanuel Bompard des
types qui savent plus s'en sortir elle
aura comme dernière victime Jean-Luc
Mélenchon le mal de plus de 50 ans pour
pouvoir elle-même porter les couleurs de
l'extrême gauche